Was ist also Qiskit?
Qiskit ist ein Open-Source Software Development Kit
für die Arbeit mit Quantencomputern
auf der Ebene von circuits,
Algorithmen und Anwendungsmodulen. Dieses SDK
ermöglicht es jedem, echte Quantencomputer direkt
vom Laptop aus zu programmieren. Mit nur zwei Zeilen Code kannst du auf
verschiedene Quantensysteme zugreifen — von supraleitenden
bis hin zu trapped-ion qubits. Möchtest du stattdessen das Verhalten eines Quantencomputers
emulieren? Ändere einfach eine einzige Zeile Code
und simuliere deine quantum circuits auf unserem Hochleistungs-
Simulator. Qiskit ist ein Werkzeug, das von Zehntausenden
von Menschen weltweit genutzt wird — alle mit dem Ziel,
die Zukunft zu gestalten. Ob du Forscher, Entwickler
oder Einsteiger bist —
Qiskit bietet eine Reihe von
Funktionen, die auf deine Bedürfnisse zugeschnitten sind,
sodass jeder Dinge tun kann
wie seinen ersten quantum circuit zu bauen,
domänenübergreifende Quantenalgorithmen auszuführen
und grundlegende Quantenphänomene zu untersuchen.
Vielleicht ist jetzt der perfekte Zeitpunkt, selbst einzusteigen
und alle Werkzeuge zu finden, die du brauchst —
darunter echte Quantenmaschinen
und das SDK über Qiskit
sowie eine Community, die dich herzlich willkommen heißt
und alle Fragen beantwortet, die du unterwegs hast.
Du kannst noch heute loslegen
auf qiskit.org.